-I had a big weekend
this weekend.
-What did you do?
-Well, I saw you for one of the
days, but you know that.
But I went to Los Angeles,
'cause we went to meet
some editors
and some media and press,
and talking about
our year of our shows.
We had a great year.
It's our fifth anniversary.
So we had our -- Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
So we talked about that.
We did that first show
we did in Central Park.
That was big.
-Oh, that was great.
-The first-ever
live show outdoors.
But then the
fifth-anniversary show special
that we had
Tina Fey and Ben Stiller.
It was like a
behind-the-scenes of our show,
but it was all scripted.
If you haven't seen it,
it's funny.
It's a tricky show,
but it was good.
And we talked about, obviously,
the Puerto Rico show.
We took our show down
to Puerto Rico,
and it was great.
And it was just --
It was really fun to --
Time to time, I go out to L.A.
just to say "hi"
to everybody out there.
And we also did a Q&A at
the Writers Guild Theater
with Guy Raz, who is the host of
"How I Built This."
If you don't know that podcast,
that should be on
your list of podcasts.
It is one of the best out there.
He is phenomenal.
But he was so great.
And I was talking to him
about L.A.
and when I was out there,
'cause I was there for a while,
doing stuff before I got "SNL,"
just struggling,
like everyone does.
But that was fun.
I got to see some old friends.
And I got to see Tom Rowan,
who's my --
This guy has been
my lawyer since
I think before I got
"Saturday Night Live."
It was like, "You need to
get one, you know,
when you're doing a contract
or something."
So, he's the best.
I mean, I've had him for
23 years, 22 years.
Anyways, I'm firing him today
because I've had --
The more I think about it,
I've had enough, yeah.
No. I'm fed up, yeah.
But he's the best guy.
I love him so much
and his wife, Marla.
They were there
in the front row.
And it reminded me of
this story.
They had a dinner party
at their house.
I used to have dinner with them
when I'd go out to L.A.
And, so, he goes, "I've got to
have dinner for you.
Come on over.
I got Carol Burnett,
Bob Newhart, Don Rickles,
Tim Conway will be
at dinner.
Yeah. So, I go over to
the house, I open the door,
and they're all there.
And I'm like "Oh, my gosh."
It was, like, fantastic.
I see -- He goes,
"This is Carol Burnett."
I go, "Hey, Carol.
Nice to meet you."
He goes, "This is Bob."
I go, "Hey, Bob.
Nice to meet you."
He goes, "This is Tim."
And Tim Conway goes, "You got to
get me the hell out of here.
I don't know these people.
I don't know who
these people are."
That was his opening line.
Yeah, It was great.
So, I did that.
And we talked about everything
we do on the show.
And, again, thank you to you,
Higgins, and The Roots,
and all of our crew and everyone
who works hard on the show.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It was fun to talk about.
I'd never really talked
that much about the show.
But then, after we
did all that --
It was Friday and Saturday.
And then I was
trying to fly back,
because I was nice enough to be
asked by the writers
to do a cameo on
"Saturday Night Live"
this Saturday.
So, I'm doing L.A.
And my man, Adam Sandler, is
hosting the show.
He's my hero, my idol.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Adam Sandler is the nicest guy.
I just love him so much.
He's just a --
-Gentleman.
-Great guy,
just loyal, good dad,
and just funny and just awesome.
I just love him so much.
So, I heard he was hosting.
He's never hosted.
-Mnh-mnh.
-I find that hard to believe.
-He didn't want to.
-That's bizarre.
-It's up to him.
No one said "no."
-I guess.
But, yeah, so, he had a crusher
of a show, I thought.
It was so great.
And he had --
Chris Rock was there,
who is one of
the funniest human beings ever.
Kristen Wiig, who is just on
a different planet.
But I loved his monologue.
It was good.
I loved -- There were so many
great sketches.
"Opera Man."
Opera Man is Robert Smigel.
-Come on.
-Right?
-Smigel and then Herlihy
helped on that one.
-Tim Herlihy was there.
And then, so, my scene was --
It was the
Sandler family reunion.
So, they had all of
his family at the reunion,
and everyone talks
like Adam Sandler.
-Yeah.
-But, like, the fake comedy
characters, like...
So, I came in...
So, I came in --
Everyone's like...
"Oh, yeah!"
So, I came in and I was talking
to Smigel and Herlihy
before the show,
'cause I was like,
"I want to make Adam laugh.
I want to see if
I can break him."
Because I didn't
get to go to rehearsal,
but I just landed just in time,
came right from the airport.
I, like, smelled like airplane.
I'm like, "I can't wait.
I'm so excited about this."
I ran. I didn't run,
but I ran to my car.
-Well, you ran to your car.
-Yeah, yeah.
But then -- So, I got out there
and I didn't even know
where to stand,
because I didn't rehearse.
So I just assumed
I stand next to Sandler.
And the cue cards are there.
You know, I'm looking at that.
So, I came out
and I read the lines like...
And then I figured
I could make him laugh,
because I can do like...
That's a deep cut.
He doesn't do that anymore.
You got to just...
So, he started laughing
a little bit.
So, anyways,
I'm usually in black ink
on the cue cards from our show.
But I forgot, I'm not the host.
-Yeah.
-So, the host is in black ink.
-Black, yeah.
-So I'm kind of
stalling for Sandler
because I thought he
forgot his line.
So I'm going like...
And I'm looking at the cue card.
And I don't know why
we even have cue cards.
It was like,
"Hibbidy-hobbidy, yaba-haba."
I don't remember if I said,
"Yabbidy-hibbidy"
or "Hibbidy-yabbidy."
I'm like,
"I don't know what to do."
Anyways, I got
to, finally, my line.
We did that.
And it was just an honor
to do it with him,
right in front of him,
'cause it's just --
And he's just such a good dude.
And he was so happy,
like, that night.
And his wife, Jackie,
and two kids were there,
and they're beautiful.
I love those kids.
And it was just --
Anyways, it was good.
And then, at the end
of the night,
he did this tribute to
Chris Farley.
-Yeah.
-And if you get a chance
to go online,
it was so beautiful and so --
It was so funny, too.
But I had heard all
the stories about Farley,
and I just -- I wish I knew him.
I got to meet him once,
but I just --
He was singing this song,
and it's great,
but it's also
a really nice tribute.
And everyone was
just crying backstage.
And it was just really touching.
I mean, not just the audience,
but everybody that worked there,
'cause the crew -- Some of
the crew -- they knew Farley.
-Yeah.
-So -- And I was next to Rock,
and it was just --
It was really emotional.
And I saw Smigel afterwards,
and, usually,
he's always joking around.
You know, he's like --
You know...whatever.
So, I saw him, and he goes,
"Hey, man, that was great."
And he's like -- I go,
"That was so touching."
He goes --
He was behind the cast,
and the cast were all kind of
hugging each other, crying,
going like,
"Yeah, we're like family."
It's like, you don't realize
it when you're there
on "Saturday Night Live" for
whatever seasons you are there.
You don't know when
some cast members
are gonna go off
to do movies or --
But that little moment of time,
that window of time,
you hang out more
than your family.
You really live with each other
and you don't realize it
until, I think,
you get older and you go back
and you go, "Oh, my gosh."
And, so, he got me
filling up, Smigel.
So I started crying
a little bit.
I came up to your office
to see if you wanted
to ride over to
the party together.
-I was already drunk.
-You don't even remember me
coming and saying
"hello" to you.
-You were there?
-I put smelling salts.
I was there?
And as I was going up, I got an
e-mail from Horatio Sanz,
who is in L.A.
And he was like, "Dude,
I'm watching the Sandler show
right now and I'm just getting
sentimental, just missing us
and missing -- You know.
And I go, "wait until
you see the end."
-Yeah.
-I go, "You're gonna see
this Farley thing
and you're just gonna lose it.
This is like
when the show first started.
But, anyways, it was just
kind of interesting
that I got a thing from Horatio.
I feel like I vibed him,
'cause me and Horatio
were office-mates and
comedy partners for years.
I wouldn't be here
if it wasn't for Horatio.
And, so, I got that.
And then I thought it was the
best part was on Sunday.
On Saturday night into Sunday,
it was trending all day,
is Farley was trending.
And I just thought, any kid that
was in mass or church Sunday
and sneaking a look at Twitter
got to see Farley's name.
And he would have
absolutely loved that,
so I think that was a...
[ Cheers and applause ]